stell dir vor eine frau teilt alles mit
ihrem mann bett kinder konto aber ein
computer entscheidet er bekommt 20 mal
mehr kredit als sie apple karte zur
verdammt sexistisch twitter tech
unternehmer david heinemeier seiner frau
sei genau das passiert apple habe
geantwortet sie diskriminieren nicht es
ist nur der algorithmus da macht man
sich schon große sorgen wenn der
einzelfall gar nicht mehr betrachtet
wird sondern ich nur als teil einer
gruppe behandelt werde
und wenn diese gruppe in der
vergangenheit schlechter gesetz gestellt
war in der gesellschaft dann wird sich
das auch auf den einzelfall auswirken
für solche anwendungen künstlicher
intelligenz fordert das europaparlament
datensätze ohne diskriminierung
auskunftsrechte der verbraucher menschen
in der entscheidungs kette und trifft
auf zustimmung
geht es dabei um größere risiken oder
gar leben und tod da sollte ein mensch
einbezogen seien
so wissen wir der arbeitet eine maschine
aber letztendlich sitzt mir auch ein
mensch der hand über den ansatz teilen
alle doch wo beginnt das risiko das
europaparlament debattiert die
kommission reguliert auch der bundestag
hörte diese woche zum thema ki
expertinnen
ich glaube dass wir uns im moment
tatsächlich in einer medial
aufgeblasenen filter blase befinden und
ständig über risiken von ki system reden
und dabei ein bisschen aus dem blick
verlieren was wir mit nicht persönlichen
daten alles an interessanten
kassensoftware dem produzieren können
doch gerade die personenbezogenen daten
sind geldwert diesem geschäft brauche es
ethische standards made in europe
es ist sehr wichtig dass wir uns als
europäer einigen wie wir das künftig
rollen
sonst werden wir weltweit niemals
einfluss sagen manche im parlament
wollen dabei weiter wollen die
beweislast im schadensfall umkehren vom
verbraucher zum anbieter denn das
problem ist dass ich ja gar nicht weiß
dass ein system nicht diskriminiert ich
habe ja überhaupt keine beweise dafür
niemand sagt mir du bekommst diesen
arbeitsplatz oder diesen kredit nicht
weil du schwarz bist oder weil du eine
frau
es heißt einfach nur unser system das
ist sehr objektiv und das hat das so
entschieden zurück zur kreditkarte
apple-gründers die bosnjak und seiner
frau ging es übrigens hinaus erforderte
die eigene firma auf mehr verantwortung
zu übernehmen